president trump has repeated his mantra
that he did
actually win the u.s election in spite
of all the
evidence and the votes that say he
didn't he's been continuing with his
legal challenges
this week even though he's not had any
success as yet in the
courts professor alan lichtman is a
political historian at american
university he's also
the author of the case for impeachment
good to see you on sky news
um before we get into the the
nitty-gritty we spoke you may remember
a few days before the election i know
you've correctly predicted every
president since i think
reagan in 1980 you told me joe biden
would win uh my question to you is was
there ever a point
on election night or the uh the hours
afterwards where you thought perhaps you
might be getting it wrong for the first
time
you know i'm 73 years old as you say
i've been doing this for now on 40 years
and i got butterflies in my stomach
every four years
because i know the bricks that will fall
on my head if i'm wrong
and absolutely i was nervous on election
night
when the results looked somewhat grim
for joe biden but on the other hand
i knew full well that the absentee
ballots were not yet counted these were
not illegal ballots these were not
ballots out of nowhere
these were legally cast votes that
weren't counted yet
and i was pretty sure they would put uh
biden over the top
but i was nervous i bet you were those
butterflies are in your stomach as you
say but uh your record is still
intact uh for another uh four years so
we'll get on to who's going to stand uh
in four years time in a moment perhaps
but uh donald trump speaking tonight
he's
he's not made many uh uh appearances in
front of the camera over the last uh
fortnight uh what did he make of what he
had to say uh he did take a swipe at the
democrats and uh
still maintains that he won the election
look what we've seen since election
night from this president
is the worst moment in the history of
the american presidency
and i say that very advisedly i've been
studying american presidents for more
than 50 years
from george washington on and never
have we seen an american president
launch such a
false disreputable attack on his
opponents
basically accusing them of a serious
felony
in reading an election not only without
evidence but contrary
to all evidence from his own cyber
security chief who he fired
and from every elected official in every
state
both republican and democrat and he's
trashing our democracy
making us a laughing stock in the eyes
of the world but he takes no reason
other than to satisfy his ego and
promote his own
selfish political purposes shame
shame shame he does of course have the
right to do so doesn't he um
under the american system and and it's
it's proper that he that he does if he
does feel that he has
a grievance it's right that he airs it
no it's not right he's the president of
the united states
and he has a responsibility to tell the
truth
to the american people and not lie
brazenly to the american people
in a way that it undermines the
integrity of our
our democracy and the faithfulness of
an election he certainly has a right to
go to court but that's quite different
and by the way
he has suffered 30 defeats in court
by judges appointed by republicans and
democrats state
and federal judges and has not had a
single consequential win that's quite
different
than propagating falsehoods and
illicitly trying to
pressure republican officials in key
states to overturn
the verdict of the people and just hand
the election to him
that's not his right it's interesting
hearing from the secretary of state in
georgia uh
a trump supporter of course saying that
uh he's disappointed by the result of
the uh the
the recount but i live by the motto that
numbers don't lie
secretary of state i believe that the
numbers that we have presented today
are correct um i mean you'd think
wouldn't you that it
that there aren't many more avenues that
donald trump can go down now
there are no legal avenues that donald
trump can go down now he has been
slapped down
by essentially every court he's gone to
and as i said there are some 30 courts
that have slapped him down
so instead of pursuing legal avenues
he is trying to overturn the verdict of
the people
to pressure republican officials in
these states just to
hand him the election regardless of the
verdict of the people
that's not the american way that's not
democratic and that is not his right
okay well we'll see what happens in the
next few days uh and weeks but just uh
finally what about four years time do
you think donald trump
will stand again
i think donald trump has a lot of
problems other than thinking about
the next presidential election he is
under criminal investigation
by the state of new york and no federal
pardon
applies to state uh criminal proceedings
he is under civil investigation by the
new york attorney general
who can also make a criminal referral he
may be under criminal investigation by
the federal
southern district of new york he has
numerous lawsuits
including one by eugene carroll saying
that he raped her and she has dna
evidence and he won't be protected once
he is no longer president
what about his supporters you know more
than 70 million people
support him and polling has shown
recently that
the majority of them believe that there
was
some jiggly pokery in the in the
election
look you know the hallmark
of an autocrat is the big lie if you say
something
often enough and loudly enough a number
of people will come
to believe you but those who believe him
are pretty much
limited to his republican bait democrats
and independents by
huge margins believe this election was
legitimate
and joe biden was the president elect
even substantial numbers of his base say
all right we may not think as yet joe
biden
is president but once the legal
challenges run their course
they're willing to accept biden okay
good to speak to you professor al
nickman political historian
many thanks indeed